history saturday morning at eight
through monday morning at eight eastern
48 hours of non-fiction books all
weekend every weekend
on book tv
today history on book tv looks at the
kennewick man
anthropologist james chatters is the
author of ancient encounters kennewick
man and the first americans it tells the
story of a skeleton found in 1996 near
kennewick washington first thought to be
of a 19th century white settler
it turned out to be 9 500 years old
mr chatter suggests that many of today's
native americans are recently diverged
from a common ancestor he talked about
his book last june at the oregon museum
of science and industry in portland
hello my name is brad yazzelino as most
of you know i am currently chair of the
speaker program for oregon
archaeological society and i'd like to
welcome you to this special event
sponsored by the oregon archaeological
society
we'd also like to thank omsi for hosting
tonight
oas as you know supports ethical
avocational archaeology and our members
work with professional archaeologists on
projects primarily in oregon and
washington
we are celebrating our 50th year this
year
and um
we had that celebration here at omsi
last january
tonight our speaker is james c chatters
he's an archaeologist and paleo
ecologist and founder of applied paleo
science a firm specializing in forensic
and archaeological consulting
he's currently adjunct associate
professor of research at central
washington university
and he's deputy coroner for benton
county
he's taught at the university of
washington and he served as senior
research scientist at pacific northwest
national laboratory
he lives in richland washington
and he's written a new book published by
simon schuster
ancient encounters kennewick man and the
first americans
this new book vividly describes the
events that unfolded almost five years
ago when a nearly complete human
skeleton was accidentally found on
public land near the banks of the
columbia river
in his role as a forensic anthropologist
and as an author jim chatters has met
the challenge of methodically assessing
and describing the ever more astonishing
truths that these bones have revealed
please let's give jim chatters a big
welcome
[Applause]
thanks brad
well since you folks are in the
archaeological society you know what
the standard story for many years has
been about how and when the americas
were peopled
um
and
i i tend to work with slides
that way i don't have to remember what
i'm going to say
uh so if someone could turn the
projector on for me i will be ready to
go brad is there someone who's going to
be focusing for me this projector has a
tendency to go in and out of focus at
random
um
so
we're gonna be looking at that but you
know what the basic story is
because
um
all the way on all the way forward
oh no okay
as a result of a number of factors
there's been a very uh
over
dominant theme in the explanation for
when folks got here and
how they peopled the continents
part of that came from an observation of
modern american indians that is 18th
19th century american indians which
europeans
thought tend to look all pretty much
alike
all pretty much like this this sioux
fellow here
they were
northeast asian people
with
the somewhat brownish skin
straight black hair and
flattened faces that are called
coronally flattened with projecting
cheekbones
that were found all the way over into
eastern asia
and
the
added to that was the evidence that was
found all over the united states into
mexico and even down as far as panama
that the earliest
at least spear points found in america
for many many years were these these are
the clovis spear points
and so the the idea developed that
one population
one small group of people perhaps as few
as a hundred folks entered the americas
by way of the bering land bridge walking
across
the barren steps
wearing
heavy
fur cloaks
and kind of always they're always
pictured this way they're always
carrying burdens on their backs they're
leaning into the wind
and it's blowing their hair back
and these intrepid folks
came through the most harsh climates you
can imagine
found their way through a narrow gap in
the ice worked their way south into
temperate north america and from that
point of origin they spread throughout
both continents within a matter of about
500 years giving rise to all
but a very few later
cultures people's languages
well this is sort of the picture that
that folks had projected
from northeast asia there was a first
migration this blue one that came down
and gave rise to the the people we refer
to as american indians or americans in
physical anthropology there was a second
group that came later
from siberia again basically the same
area entered into alaska and only much
much later you know around a thousand
years ago and and younger and less
worked their way down into
more southerly parts of the united
states and became the navajo the apache
and a few other groups
in that
sort of this region of the country and
the final group was the eskimo who came
along from coastal asia and expanded
into north america working their way out
into the aleutian islands and out into
the islands of the of northern canada
this was a prevailing view and this was
i what i thought was going on
everything seemed to fit
then
on a hot july day in 1996 i had a call
from the coroner who began the same way
he always begins when he gives me a call
he says hey buddy
have you got time to look at some bones
and since it was a boat race day
we have the unlimited hydroplanes that
come to the tri-cities once a year
and
self-respecting adults in the tri-cities
most of them at least
don't go to the boat races we tend to
hide out and get away from the thunder
boats
and so i was i was at home that day and
i said sure come on over we're just
staying out of the heat
so about seven o'clock he arrives
and what he presents to me is a plastic
bucket you know one of these five gallon
detergent buckets that that you see so
many of these white buckets and in it is
a drawstring bag from somewhere like the
bond
and i open that up the draw sprint
string bag and this is what i looked
down on
i've got a long narrow skull with a
fairly prominent brow area and a nice
obviously projecting nose
it comes white out from under the face
and heads out there
so i have a sense okay first thought
oh okay good uh this is one i'm going to
be working on for quite some time
because it looks like i've probably got
someone who's related to the more recent
occupants of the area i.e he
fits better the
the characteristics at least from this
first view of
people of european background than he
does the american indians i'm used to
used to seeing a lot of in that area
they wash out of the riverbank a lot
then i
take and i
pick that up and i look down below it
and
underneath is a portion of the face it's
the the upper jaw the maxilla
and that
also has characteristics that are not
inconsistent with the first few
and the most distinct thing i remember
seeing is that the nasal opening has
walls that project out on either side of
it
this is a characteristic we only tend to
see in
nowadays
in in folks of european background
or european or middle eastern especially
middle eastern area and north africa
that kind of area western eurasia and
north africa
and
i also look at the the tooth row from
above still and it has a very distinct
ridge where the canine is
you guys can most of you in this room
will be able to run your finger forward
you'll catch that ridge and your finger
kind of lump around it
back and forth
that's a characteristic again that
folks of
of a western eurasian background tend to
have
and people of eastern eurasia and
american background didn't tend not to
have
so it all seems to fit and then i flip
that over and here i get these flattened
teeth
ground off just smooth as can be
and i think
oh this isn't gonna this isn't quite
right i look back at it and i notice
that the skull has the sutures all
closed
it's an older guy all the suture cloak
are closed in the skull all the bones
separate bones that make up the skull
and they're obliterated i can't see even
where they were
okay
this is an older guy
he's just worn his teeth off he's been
using stone ground flower this must be
19th century we're dealing with here
right
so i went out to look at the site and
the light was about like this except it
wasn't foggy that day uh when we got out
there because it was moving toward
evening
the sun was setting
and we went out to look at the beach
where these bones had been found by a
couple of young men who were
sneaking into the boat races
they were a little young to be had
carrying beers in each hand and so they
wanted to get those beers drunk before
they got into where it would catch them
get them into trouble
and they're walking along and
the one fellas walking in the water
which is a smart thing to do because
it's 108 degrees out that day
and he's walking along and he says and
uh in front of him he sees this
round rock and he thinks oh good
that rock looks like a skull i'm gonna
trick my pal dave here into thinking
that's a skull
he says hey man look dude
there's a skull down there that's a
human head
you know come on over here man check
this out and he gets his friend that
goes look at this somebody's been
murdered he reaches down picks this rock
up flips it over and it's got teeth
sobered him up right away right
so they'd called in the coroner and they
called in the police the police got the
coroner and the coroner got me
so
i get out there and and this is a view
from the next day but this is kind of
what the bones looked like on the shore
they'd floated up on top of the sand
they were literally sitting on top of
the sand
uh underwater at the time we were there
previous day the water got dropped after
the boats were done racing
and it looked like this very solid bones
good good solid broken straight across
so it was clear they were not recent
bones they weren't dead like five ten
years ago they've been there for a while
but they were in excellent condition and
we were able to collect a lot of the
bones from the shoreline that that night
we didn't want to leave them there
because the newspapers had already found
out about it by following the police
scanner and they'd already been there
and
we'd have curious folks by seven o'clock
the next morning so we got him picked up
but when i got him back and and after a
number of weeks got got pieces collected
this is what the skull looked like
actually this is a cast of the skull
and what distinguishes this fellow is
he's got this projecting midface
his nose just comes right straight out
from the bottom and the top and from the
sides so he has a substantial nose to
him
a very distinct chin
a lower jaw that kind of recedes
backwards
a relatively delicate jaw for a big man
is as big as this his cheekbones don't
project in front of his upper brow
and
generally he's just a long narrow high
cranium individual these are
characteristics that we don't ordinarily
see in america
and if you can compare this is a this is
a american indian male here at gray and
here's the outline of kennewick man laid
over it you can see what the differences
are his face is projecting far forward
and this is this is a characteristic we
very often see in many populations of
western eurasia and so that seemed
consistent with my first thought
the bones had been on the beach
in association with a lot of historic
items historic trash from a homestead
one of the objects of which was a a
bone-handled pewter inlaid knife
that fit a groove in the left knee
and okay well this guy's been buried
he's had this object in the grave with
him and so it's impressed into the bone
so everything seemed to fit together and
then
the next morning i'm cleaning the bones
off
and lo and behold there's this gray
thing showing up inside the pelvis
right in here
now
um
this doesn't quite fit
but it was not possible to see exactly
what it was it it looked i don't have i
didn't have rugged eyesight then i still
don't but i got better glasses now
and i couldn't see it very clearly as
much light as i could get on it i
couldn't see it very clearly so um and i
was only looking at an area about the
size of the end of my little finger the
rest it was encrusted with with sediment
so we took it in and had an x-ray
and couldn't see it so it was clearly
stone x-rayed it again
or cat scanned it and got the red bone
out of the way and it was this
i'm sorry this doesn't focus any better
it's a cat scan it's not a photograph so
it's not getting any better than this
but
it's a round based
serrated edge so you can't see the
serrations you can see a little bit
right here
broken
dark point
or spear point
two inches long an inch wide a quarter
inch thick substantial item to be healed
inside somebody's pelvis
looked about like the thing on the right
originally it was probably something on
the order of
three and a half inches long
and
jagged edged like this
so this this thing had been uh embedded
in him at some force now
the thing that's strange about this is
okay this style of projectile point many
of you in the audience will recognize as
a cascade point right
these are supposed to be oh you know
most ordinary most often five to nine
thousand years old they're not supposed
to be from the 19th century
the problem here is that
other people elsewhere in the world made
these things
into historic times folks on the oregon
coast or in the here in willamette
valley and along along the coast used
them
northern californians had items like
that in their in their
uh these are ceremonial toolkits the
spears that they carried around for for
ceremonies
and uh
australians were making these things
into the 1920s
so if this man had this healed inside
his pelvis he could have received it
anyplace in the world literally any
place where there's stone age people uh
stone age people stone using people
still stone age is kind of a
meaningless term
but
so given the
incongruity the great disparity between
this man's physical characteristics and
this spear point
we got together decided that we needed
to run a radio carbon date
let the corps of engineers know that
that was our decision they concurred
that that was the best course of action
and we went on
sending this small bone in the left hand
the university of california riverside
had a radiocarbon date run
that date
came back let me see if i've
yeah that date came back
the equivalent of 9500 years old
okay now
when this happens i'm
i'm standing at the top of the stairs
and i'm saying goodbye to my son who's
on his way back to college
my son is an economist
and uh i'm on the phone and he's saying
goodbye and i can get get the
pick the phone up and it's donna kerner
from the university of california
riverside laboratory she says jim
i got your
date and i said uh
what is it she says
are you sitting down
i said no no just give it to me i i got
stuff i'm doing here you know saying
goodbye to my kid he says okay
um
in radiocarbon years it's 8 400 years
old
and i just got out of hoop and my son
looks up what the hell's wrong dad you
know i said the skeleton it's 8 500
years old he's 8400 years old he says
okay whatever
uh i didn't instill excitement in
anthropology or archaeology in my son
so
um
but
it meant a great deal because within
a few days
of that date being known
the corps of engineers stepped in seized
control of the skeleton
and at the demand of of the local tribes
in the area
ordered a halt to all studies
so i got a little way through my studies
i got some pictures taken and things
like that
and then
the coroner came to get the bones
over the next number of years
one of the things the core did was not
only say we couldn't work with the
skeleton but they also covered the site
up where the bones had come from
this is what the site looked like after
it was covered up you saw the earlier
picture right it's a nice little
riverbank with you know sloughing bank
but
trees this is what it looked like
in the spring of 1998
it's now 20 foot tall willows the entire
thing
it's hard to get in and out of there
these days so they basically foreclosed
further study and there's a lot going on
with relation to this
eight
prominent anthropologists physical
anthropologists and archaeologists have
filed suit in federal court
to
for the opportunity to conduct studies
before any repatriation takes place that
was five years ago this is now the case
goes to
uh the judge
final arguments tuesday morning at 10
o'clock in in hatfield courthouse
and that is all i'm going to say about
that
okay
because that's not what i'm in this for
i'm in this to get a sense of
what happened in the past
so
for someone who'd been doing archaeology
by that time for 35 years
i was pretty devastated this was the
biggest most exciting discovery i'd ever
been part of
and i didn't have time to complete the
work i needed to do on it
but i did console myself with the fact
that i had quite a bit of information to
work with nonetheless
i had
photographs
cat scans x-rays
dental x-rays
and a cast
plus various notes i'd taken on the
characteristics of the bone
so i set about figuring out
what kenwick's man's situation was
well overall
there were about 350 bone fragments
i spent quite a number of days going
back to that beach after the boats went
over and the wakes exposed new bones and
picked the bones up
what's shown in yellow here is what
there was of the skeleton
it's almost complete
there are only a bit a few bits missing
in fact these are just crushed areas
those bones are there they're just in
fragments
uh we're missing mainly small bones of
the hands and feet a couple of ribs
and a couple of teeth and that's all
most late prehistoric skeletons i get
aren't this good shape
the bone is solid it's undistorted it's
in tremendous condition
it's the remains of a man who was in his
40s
i think most likely 40 to 45 years old
there are differences of opinion on that
so that's one thing to resolve be
resolved if other studies get done
it's uh he stood about five foot seven
five foot eight inches tall or five
eight five nine inches tall sorry
somewhere between five seven and five
ten
and weighed roughly 160 pounds he was in
other words built
about like i am
i'm
5 foot 645 pounds
that's exactly the same body proportion
or weight to weight to height proportion
as he was
he had long legs
i don't but
relatively shorter torso and longer legs
than i do his lower leg
the tibia was long relative to the upper
more like a person from the tropics than
a person from the arctic
he had been injured many many times
he had you can see it in that previous
slide
he's got a little nick in his forehead
here
he had
and it's you know it's either a small
depressed fracture it's possible it's a
it's a
a cyst that works its way into the bone
but you know it's a good place you can
scratch the cyst right out so i don't
think it's likely to be that in that
position
he was he had multiple broken ribs
he'd broken at least six of his ribs a
total of seven times or more
three of the ribs
at least
never fully healed back together they
healed but they didn't reconnect
so that when he breathed in and out
those ribs flexed in places they weren't
supposed to flex
as we breathe in our chest rises
as we breathe out our chest sinks
the diaphragm is doing the work in part
creating a vacuum but the ribs are
actually working too and they lift the
muscles lift the rib cage up
when you have broken ribs to either side
like this you had them here and here
broken on both sides this is called a
flail chest it moves the opposite
direction for what it's supposed to so
the vacuum created by the diaphragm
sucks the ribs in
and
on exhale pushes them back out again
they flex back and forth
i've had many broken ribs
none of them failed to heal back
together but they still hurt
15 years later they still hurt i can't
imagine what this fellow felt when he
exerted himself
he also had injured a left arm
he had a creaky neck because he
arthritis and his neck he had arthritis
in both elbows a little bit in both
knees i know how he feels there
and uh
uh to
there was a an ailment that had
afflicted his skull it was this this is
showing this side of the head right
about the temple
and
what this shows is there's bone death
here it's this hollowed area kind of
honeycombed area and here's the bone
healing
this was an infection somewhere in his
face area
that was causing death of the bone it
was it was cutting off the circulation
of the bone causing it to die
and it was in the healing process but it
had not fully healed
so it's apparent that this fellow may
have had an infection going on at the
time of his death and this may have
caused his demise but another
possibility
is that spear point stuck in his pelvis
and this is one of the most interesting
things we're dealing with here
uh this gentleman
had that two inches of stone in his p in
his hip
from the angle at which it lays in the
bone
it's apparent that it entered from about
this angle
if you're i'm facing you about like so
above and to the right
it's the exact position you'd have if
the spear was thrown directly at him and
he went like this
he's a right hander he's always going to
turn left he's going to dodge he's going
to go this way he's not going to go that
way
so he's he's turning this way
it catches him anyhow
half an inch
less
movement would have severed the major
arteries of his abdomen killed him
outright within a few seconds
half an inch more
misses him completely
so you could kind of say he was
fortunate
that it didn't hit him a little more
deeply than it did
now wounds like this don't ever heal
not entirely
it's extremely rare for them to heal
spontaneously or to for them to dis
dislodge the infection that comes with
that foreign object
spontaneously nowadays you have to do it
with rather extreme measures of surgery
and antibiotics
but what happens is they form an
infection pocket around the stone
of the object
and that infection is walled off by the
body so you're safe from it but it's
always there
and
if you
reopen that wound somehow
it will reinfect and can cause blood
blood poisoning and death so this may
also have done a man but the thing
that's really troubling about it other
than death of course which is troubling
in its own right
is the possibility or the probability
that it has to drain when it gets
infected and there's a channel right
through here that you can't see too well
in this version
where it drained off
so every so often this fellow's wound
festers up
and erupts through his skin right about
there
okay
so i get a sense of what kennewick man
is like now one of the things about ken
mcmahon that was unusual too is he's got
a very unusual looking
visage
he doesn't look like he's from around
here
but we're talking 9 500 years ago it's
very important that everybody recognize
this
we're not talking about europeans here
9 500 years ago
the populations of the world that we now
distinguish from each other on these
racial terms that we use
hadn't really diverged to that extent
yet
we're talking about a long time ago
before those categories ever developed
either physically or socially so we're
not in that game right now
but
a lot has been made of that in the
public press and by some of my
colleagues who are kind of fixated on
the issue of race these days
and
one of the things that they said is well
he's probably just an unusual looking
indian
he's probably from a normal american
indian looking population he's just an
unusual guy he's just an extreme
character individual and that's possible
say he's uh i've never seen one like him
before none of my other colleagues have
seen any like him in the late
prehistoric period so that's something
on the order of 10 or 20 000 individuals
that we're
looking at overall
so let's just say on the minimum he
might be a one in a thousand example
but still you know we don't have any
others like him so it's a good chance
that he's just that odd fellow that just
doesn't fit the norm
or perhaps not
when i was first investigating this case
two days after the skeleton turned up
the tribes had been demanding a second
opinion because the paper picked up on
my first impression that i told the
coroner about it probably being an early
settler
died and been married in a family plot
along the river
and i was up looking at skeletons
i was up having a colleague look at the
skeleton the kenoik man skeleton to give
her assessment
without any input from me it's like okay
here are the bones you do your thing i'm
gonna go away
so while she's looking at the bones i'm
walking around the room looking at
other skeletons they had laid out
because they were doing their inventory
that's required by law
and on the shelf
along the wall i saw this one skull this
one right here
and the characteristics it had in the
brow area
on the underside and along the back of
the skull in the position of the of the
jaw musculature on the skull were
virtually identical to the ones on the
kennewick skull
now this is when we first still thought
this guy was modern right
so
katie bursts out okay i got it figured
out and i said well why do you think it
is he says ah it's caucasian mail
i say you're sure he says yeah i'm
absolutely sure about that i said okay
well you got another one over there in
the corner
so when we got the radio carbon date
back on kenwick man it's like
let's check this guy out too
and what do you know he comes out 9 000
years old
he's almost the same age
so we've got two now the probability of
finding one one in a thousand is
obviously one in a thousand
the
probability of having two out of the
only two early skeletons you have
is one in a million it's extremely
unlikely
so this is probably what these early
folks were like
these characteristics that make these
unique so we're talking about another
population of a carrot with
characteristics we did not know existed
this gets interesting we looked further
at this fellow
he's got red ochre spread on his head
you can see a little bit of the
coloration all the lights are masking it
here he's got red pigment that was
probably smeared on his face either he
wore it when he was alive as a as a form
of
adornment
or more likely it was spread on him in
death so this fellow was clearly buried
in the ground
on that
side that still has the pigment on it
okay i already ran the radiocarbon date
this gives you a sense of how little
material is used for radiocarbon dating
the tiny fragments in that vial there
are enough for
quite a number of radiocarbon dates it
doesn't take much material anymore to do
it you can do it with how much tom what
is it about the size of a sunflower seed
one of the people in the audience is one
of the world's experts in radiocarbon
dating
tom where'd you go
yes about the size of a sunflower seed
he said
thanks
that's tom in the picture
okay
all right now we got a pattern
something close to a pattern forming in
the northwest
what i did uh
i began to wonder
how widespread is this over the united
states
and i began to take a look at the other
skeletons that had been found in this
same time span
now before you get the sense that i'd
never worked on ancient skeletons before
this is the marmus rock shelter site
when i was in my middle teens
one
afternoon my father brought home a box
full of bone fragments
a graduate student who'd been working at
this site the marmot's rock shelter site
had been
uh once they'd finished the excavations
of this site he had gone through with a
bulldozer cut it wide open down the
middle
yike
there it goes
here's the ski there's the shelter
here's the trench he cut
and
found these bone fragments at the bottom
of that high bank
and he thought good i'll be able to use
these bone fragments to radiocarbon date
the geology is a geology graduate
student you know
so at the bottom of this he turns them
into my dad who ran a radiocarbon dating
lab
and dad said well i'm not going to
radiocarbonate these these are human
and his principles wouldn't allow him to
do that but
besides there wasn't enough bone there
anyway to get a good radiocarbon date
given the methods that people were using
in 1966
1964 actually in this case
so
uh they came and they
sat
in the cabinet in my basement
in my room in the basement
and periodically i'd take them out put
them on the table and put the pieces
together
and after a while i'm able to piece
together three big fragments of skull
and
after a few more pieces were found later
on they
this is what there was
this is the
marmos man
11 000 plus years old
but it had been cremated this individual
was actually a woman she'd been cremated
marmos man was a woman that's fairly
common
um
sounds like something very modern
doesn't it
okay um
the tiny fragments this is all there was
found of it
she'd been cremated
but this
created a great deal of excitement
because here we have what turns out to
be at least they estimated based on the
geology at least 9 000 years old which
made her at the time the oldest known
human skeleton in north america
that had been reasonably dated
so a great
excavation ensued
and we found additional fragments of the
skeleton
including a cremation hearth inside the
rock shelter that contained the remains
of six individuals there were four out
front six inside
but they were all burned up these are
the little tiny pieces
fragments
that they were found in pieces about his
maximum size about the big as my little
finger not much you can learn from
someone who's been cremated to that
level
this is yours truly sitting there
at the ripe old age of 19 working on
this stuff
so i hadn't
it wasn't the first time ken wake man
and the other fellow which we have named
stickman for reasons that are explained
in my book i won't go into them now
but
this wasn't the first
time and i wanted to go into physical
anthropology but
i didn't really want to study the
ancient skeletons because we already
knew what they were about right they
were just like modern american indians
there wasn't anything to learn
besides most of them were really small
this is a site where one of them was
found this is this is arlington springs
on
in the channel islands
off california
and in this great ravine
back what what year was it tom i forget
59 1959
a set of bone fragments was found in the
bank of this thing
and
here is what it looks like
there's a piece of a leg bone
in there
that's all there is you can't even see
it it's it's virtually masked
but that block has sat in the museum in
santa barbara for all this time
but that's all it was a few fragments
here a few fragments there and besides
they all look the same anyway so who
really cared so i didn't go into that i
was interested in other things i was
interested in pathologies and that kind
of stuff i still am
but when i went and looked at the
situation as it is now
with new methods of radiocarbon dating
and
and a lot more studies taking place in
the 30 years since
and here's what we see there are
approximately 39 individuals
older than 9 000 years
found in
north america one of them
this one here
is from canada
the rest are from the united states we
don't have any decent dating on any of
the mexican finds as
as yet
of these individuals
most of them
are mere fragments this is a skull cap
and there's a couple of teeth in there
and one or two fragments of the rest of
the skeleton
this is what was known as marmus iii
this is another skeleton from the mars
rock shielder this is a man like 20 to
30 years old
and there's nothing much left of him
most of them are in that condition or
like the early arlington springs femur
which dates at uh
close to
close to 12 000 really occur
close to she's close to 13 000 years old
actually
some of them however are in really good
shape this is the one that's in the best
condition
that we know of and we still do have him
fortunately this is the spirit cave
mummy this fellow is not only a skeleton
but he's wearing his moccasins
he's wrapped in a rabbit fur blanket
man that made it an unknown way
previously unknown way he's wrapped in a
blanket on top of that
woven out of fine hemp indian hemp
in a herringbone pattern it's just a
diamond diamond pattern it's a beautiful
thing
a fine cloth
he dates back
around at around 10 500 years
he's from a long time ago
so he's in in the best shape of all
but
all together of those that are in good
enough shape to conduct studies on
and the kind of study that i'm talking
about is a kind that allows us to get a
sense of the person and we often
archaeologists are always studying bones
you know animal bones stones remains of
houses
you know and most often what we're doing
is we're working with trash that people
left behind
we don't get we get a sense of where
people lived what they ate what they
lived in but we don't get a sense of how
they were as people
what did they look like
how did it feel to be them and we can
get when we when we have human skeletons
to work with we really get a chance to
see how it felt to be them
how did it feel to be kenwick man
you breathe in your chest hurts you walk
your legs leg hurts every so often you
got this crud you know weeping down your
leg but you're a tall sturdy guy and
you're tolerating it because what else
are you going to do
you just live through it
this gives you a real sense of what
people's lives were like
well what i did was i went and studied
all the skeletons i could get access to
in north america and i even went on to
south america to investigate some of
those in brazil in the course of working
on this book
and what i learned was really
astonishing
and gave me a sense of what people were
like in ways that i didn't know first
thing i found out was was
how they came to be discovered
very few of them were actually
discovered on purpose this is a a rock
shelter in
texas
where two amateurs
much like yourselves in fact very good
amateurs
excavated for
many years very meticulously keeping
things in exactly the same way as the
professionals did they did stratigraphic
drawings they did photographs every
level they went down
they kept things in tremendous
perfusion they kept every bone fragment
every chip the whole thing
this is in the 1960s they were doing
this they were doing as good a job if
not better than most professional
anthropologists at the time
as they're working through and we're
looking down now on on this this view as
they're working through they find this
pile of
of limestone slabs down about so far
beneath the surface
and underneath the
set of limestone slabs you can see right
here
they found two skulls
showing from underneath when they
excavated further below that
they found two complete skeletons flexed
tightly and laid directly against each
other the body the skeleton of a 12 year
old girl
and a
40-ish man
in a single grave
and this you can just you get a real
poignant sense of this you know you've
got to you've got to get a sense from
just looking at this at how the family
felt at losing two members
simultaneously
how the community felt
and they they took care of them really
well and i'm sorry this isn't going to
show very well with all the lights on
but
they had a lot of things in there they
had several turtle shells these are
probably for carrying fire and other
things or boxes in effect there's a
turtle shell here
there were roughly 80 marine shell beads
mainly with the mail most of the
artifacts were with the mail
stone chipping these are these are
antler beams for chipping stone here's a
fine pointed
bone item for doing the fine pressure
flaking on the points there was a a
a red shaft wrench for straightening the
shafts this fellow made his own
spear equipment
and perhaps made it for other people as
well his forearms were developed to the
extent that it looks like he really
worked his forearm muscles a great deal
so apparently chipping stone was one of
the things this fellow
tended to specialize in
with the girl there was a needle
just a needle found down around her
waist apparently had been in a pouch of
some kind
along the side of her body
most of the fines
that one was found intentionally most of
the fines have actually been found by
accident
uh and reported by citizens like the two
somewhat inebriated young men who found
kenwick man
this is a gravel pit in southern idaho
where
a skeleton
over 12 000 years old was found
washed or weathering out
again in extremely good condition found
way down in a in a deposit of wind blown
sand
this young woman was apparently
once she died she actually lay on the
ground surface and her body became just
articulated and scattered over the
surface
her lower jaw was more than a meter and
a half away from her skull
so buried under six feet of sand that
doesn't have ordinarily happened by
itself so her body had been moved about
probably after it began to deteriorate
this is uh known as the bill skeleton
this is the oldest
uh well-preserved skeleton that was ever
found in north america it's been
reburied long ago
with her also
was a needle
and a few other a needle a knife and a
few decorative items and that was about
all it was with her that was apparently
the thing she had on her at the time
these needles are so fine that they
begin to give us a sense that that story
about
people wearing heavy cloaks and you know
skin robes with fur still attached to
them and trudging through the wind and
the snow
may not be very accurate
these needles are too small to show skin
with they're not strong enough what's
increasingly being found all over the
world in the late crisis and like
paleolithic is that
these little needles aren't made for
sewing skin they're made for sewing
cloth
these folks already were using well-made
cloth
to make their clothing
and other items with
the the blanket that that spirit caveman
was found in was sewn together along the
edges
he was wrapped in it and then it was
sewn together
these are fabric needles
so um
another other preconception bites the
dust
when you take a look at these
individuals collectively
there's sort of an image that that
appears a lot of details about their
lives that we really
didn't expect to see i certainly didn't
expect to see them they don't again fit
the pattern we expect from the ancients
the males it's a spirit cave spirit cave
is a mummy so you can't see his skull
directly this is a stereolithograph this
is a computer generated
three-dimensional model
that's why it's got this interesting
grid pattern to it
in his late
30s early 40s
here's
the orange this is the cast of the
browns valley skull from minnesota he's
been reburied just last year
he was in his middle thirties
this is the horn shelter male
unfortunately it's a bit dark and the
lights are masking it and this but this
is the very robust but but tiny is about
so tall
uh male from horn shelter you can see
the distinct heavy brow on him and the
receding cheekbones and the distinct
chin
and badly worn teeth this man probably
died of dental abscess
in fact many of the people in the past
died of dental abscess and here's wick
man spirit caveman was in his early 40s
can we man's in his 40s
this is the norm for the males
most of them are dying in the late 30s
early 40s
except for
uh one one fellow who got lost in a cave
in colorado and never made it back out
one who was
at least eaten if not killed and eaten
by a bear in southeast alaska
another was killed in southern british
columbia by a landslide
and yet another was stabbed to death by
one of his fellow men
he was a teenager and he's got stab
wounds two stab wounds in his rib cage
one goes in pulls the thing out and
stabs it in again and takes it back out
and takes it home with them wherever
they were
it wasn't a throne spear he was actually
stabbed
we also see
that the pattern that i saw in the
characteristic i saw in kenwick man of
the long limbs
the elongated lower leg the elongated
lower arm is the norm in these fellows
they don't have the body of some of a
population that made its way through the
arctic
after having lived there for a long time
arctic populations because of the need
to maintain body heat have strong
natural selection in their body form
people who have attenuated bodies long
thin limbs
slender bodies don't last too well in
the cold because their surface areata
body volume ratio is really quite
high
they freeze to death
okay hypothermia is really kind of a
major force in natural selection when
you're in the arctic
so they don't do too well
people in the tropics on the other hand
don't do too well with short thick
bodies because they don't shed heat fast
enough
so there's a strong selection for
slender bodies in the tropics and thick
bodies
short-lived thick bodies
in the north
now europeans especially northern
europeans tend to have
short shorter thicker limbs and thicker
bodies than people in the tropics do
these early fellows
have the body proportion of someone from
east africa
new guinea somewhere like that not what
you'd expect in the arctic this was a
real surprise
i thought we'd see arctic body form for
this time and we don't
so what it means either is that that
natural selection isn't as strong as we
thought it was
or there's a secondary need to maintain
long legs to be able to tread rapidly
over the ground so there's something
that's counteracting the problem of of
heat loss
or we're dealing with a situation where
these folks have never spent much time
in the arctic they went through the
arctic to get here probably but they
didn't spend a whole lot of time there
and consequently natural selection did
not alter the morphology of their bodies
to any good extent or didn't didn't
select out those that were the wrong
size
so that's an interesting factor
we also find
unexpectedly that these fellows are
injured extensively
this is one of the most this is of the
ones i know of this is the most injured
population i've seen evidence of
most of the males have serious injuries
they've got there's some minor injuries
broken hands broken feet um
kenwick man's got a broken elbow there's
one with a with a spinal fracture there
are four of them with dings in the front
of the head
three on the left and one on the right
there are broken ribs
any number of infections afflicting
their bodies it looks as if there's some
penetrating wounds in their bodies or or
skin tearing injuries that that cause
systemic infections and so there there's
damage to the bone from systemic
infection these guys are getting injured
a great deal of
the small number we have
three quarters have serious injuries
that's an extremely high frequency
the pattern of those injuries is similar
to the pattern we see in
in one distinct modern population of
humans
it's actually an occupation
rodeo riders
a lot of breaks in the forearms in the
chest and the skull
head arm
chest not much in the legs and feet
so
what is it that rodeo riders do
that causes them to be injured so often
other than a slight shortage of fear
what is it they have
they yeah they ride wild animals they
engage in close quarter interaction with
large dangerous creatures
these people apparently did the same
kind of thing
but when we look at the pattern of those
injuries one of the things that comes to
the floor is
a lot of these are skull fractures
and two of them which aren't counted in
the rodeo rider pattern
are spear wounds one guy gets killed
stabbed to death and the guy gets a
spear wound in his pelvis that he heals
from but he still
probably had to dodge on its way there
it may very well be then the pattern of
these injuries on the skull
three whacks on the left side one whack
on the right is 75 right 25 left for the
handedness of anybody swinging at them
that's about the pattern of left-handers
versus right-handers
in the population globally
so there's a good chance even though
it's a small population it's this
you know these are suggestions rather
than anything else because the numbers
are so small but
what it looks like is the large
dangerous animals these fellow fellows
may have been act interacting with were
each other
to a significant extent
and we may see a sense of why that was
here in a moment
here's the stab wound of one of them
that's the stab wound in the young man
but it's dark in this situation
it's in a rib now
the females
are facing a different situation
the males tend to be pretty good size
most of the males average male is just
my size five foot six
that's bigger than the later prehistoric
populations in the northwest anyway
where they're about males are about five
foot four
but kenwick man is the largest at around
five eight five nine then there's
another fellow that's around five seven
the rest are in the five six range
and little old horn shelter around five
five foot four the guy that got lost in
the cave was even smaller
but
when we
look at the females they're a lot
smaller
average size of the females is five feet
tall
they range from about 4 10 or 4 9 4 10
which is my daughter's full grown
daughter's size it's about that big two
five foot one or five foot two
fairly narrow range which you would tend
to expect
in any population but they they're quite
small they're also very very delicately
built
you can get that sense from here this is
this is the the upper arm bone of a
young woman who uh either died in the la
brea tar pits or was buried in the
liberia tar pits around
roughly 10 000 years ago
that's a one centimeter
scale her bone is not more than not much
more than one centimeter wide not much
more than about that went far across
very small very delicate and this is not
an exception this is more like the norms
he's one of the smallest but it still
tends to be a pattern
this is all there is of her by the way
except for her skull
and it was
moved around in the moving tar and
scattered about
so they're really quite quite tiny and
and
they also have some rather distinct
characteristics that seem to be common
to them
they have relatively short as in from
here to here
faces
short narrow faces
otherwise the head is very similar to
the males it's long and narrow
but they are always just about every one
of them has this what's called
pragmatism it's the projection of
the the tooth row it's called alveolar
prognosis
and this is a characteristic that's
common uh in nowadays
i don't mean this in anything but this
is something to describe you so you know
what it means
in people in sub-saharan africa
not not northeast africa they don't look
like this but sub-saharan africa
new guinea
and the philippines
it's that projection of the tooth roll
so they're really quite quite distinct
in that respect but they're very small
and have these very distinctive faces
they also are showing some rather strong
nutritional problems this is the young
woman again from the la brea tar pits
her face has been partly reconstructed
with paper mache-like stuff right
through there so that really isn't her
nose bridge
this was done a long time ago
and her forehead is also replaced she
doesn't have a forehead either but
this young woman has a condition that
results from an anemia frequently
it's a honeycomb character of the upper
brow
another thing that we see
fairly often
and it's shown up in the females where
it's been x-rated and one of the males
is this see these little white lines
these are
periodic
nutritional stress
she's going hungry every so
often there are 15 of them on her femur
this is her her thigh bone
15 growth interruptions which is about
the number of years it takes for her to
grow to that size
so perhaps every year she's undergoing
you know
a period of hunger she was the tallest
of the group
she might have been substantially bigger
if she'd been better fed
this is a common thing so the females at
least
are under nutritional stress they're
showing showing signs of not getting
enough to eat
and one of the ways this may manifest
itself isn't how old they get to be
the males again are ending up in their
late 30s early 40s
i'm sorry about the graph i know it's
late in the day but i had to use this
one it's too hard to explain this
otherwise
the females
are mostly dying
much younger
if we take a look at those that are old
enough to start having kids so we're
picking them up right about here
if we include those what we find is that
the females
are dying on the average of 19 to 23
years old
the adult females are dying in that
range this has severe implications and
you can see the pattern is really a very
strong one
every new person that turns up
the odds are they're going to be in that
age range and the last two three females
that have turned up have been that same
age
they're not all on this graph a couple
of them been since i made this graph
so
it's a pattern a very strong one that
the women aren't living very long
the men are living a long time they're
getting beaten up the women aren't
living very long they're not getting
beaten up pretty much
which is i guess a small consolation
um
but when you take into consideration
this is the number of individuals that
don't make it to puberty
and old enough to tell what sex they are
it's a quarter of the individuals are
making it past the weaning stage and not
making it to reproductive age
so if these women are are beginning
beginning they reach monarchy they're
they're beginning their periods they're
old enough to start having children
odds are they're starting to do that
around 15 years old very active people
without enough food tend to to reach
minor much later than than people who
are much better fed hence the fact that
kids are having extremely young these
days
but if they're starting at around 15
years old and they're dying on that
outside range of 23 years they're only
having
uh at most around
uh 2.6 2.7 kids per female
given a spacing of about 4.25 years and
i don't have time to go into that but
that's about the spacing that they seem
to have had based on
indications of when people were weaned
about weeds about three and a half years
and that that reduces your fertility so
being breastfed is reducing the woman's
fertility
so when you get that situation what's
happening is
you've got
2.62.7 kids
a quarter of them are dying before they
reach puberty
you're not replacing your population
anymore you're just barely making it you
might be making it two
persons two
offspring per female
this is not a way to maintain a
population and this may explain why we
don't see these people anymore
it also suggests that the idea that
people came into north america a tiny
group and spread rapidly throughout the
continents and people them all in 500
years is unlikely
not going to be maintaining a fast
growth rate under those circumstances so
this is one of the most interesting
findings of the of the investigation i
conducted
one of the things that everybody always
wants to know about these early folks is
who were they more appropriately
everybody seems to want to know what
kind of modern people do they belong to
well it's important to recognize in this
situation
that modern groups as we now know them
did not exist back then
the only way we can understand those
people and who they are is to go back
from their time and look at their same
time to understand to whom they might
who to whom they were related
in their time and before it
the reason for that is
not all human populations that ever
existed still have offspring today the
majority don't
the majority of us in this room will not
have offspring will not have descendants
9 000 years from now
that's simply the way the role of the
dice goes
so there are many populations that are
no longer with us
it's not possible to link people
back then to any one group
now
it's not even not only not possible it's
not appropriate
but who did who were these people most
like
among modern people and who with whom
might they share some common ancestry
it's a slightly different different
question
still has some pitfalls in it
one of the ways this has been
investigated
is to look at genetics
genetic characteristics of the teeth
genetic characteristics of the skull
mitochondrial genetics that is the
genetics in this that are found in the
little organelles inside our cells
one of the ways that it's done on fossil
skeletons
is what's called morphometrics it's
looking at the overall morphology of the
skull as determined statistically by a
large number of measurements
this is not as some people would want
you to know i want you to think this is
not phrenology and this is not an
attempt to assess
racial
brain capacities or anything like that
it's simply an attempt to try and
understand what the pattern of human
movements has been in the past period
so this is a whole series of
measurements and this is richard jantz
he's actually one of the chemical man
plaintiffs he'll be here in a couple
days
uh he's making his measurements with a
three-dimensional digitizer
he doesn't even know what those
measurements are when he makes them they
go straight into the computer
and what he's found in his measurements
here's a here's a graph
and what we're looking at in these
different
different figures here are different
modern human populations from different
parts of the globe
human populations
pattern geographically
in their skull shapes in their genes
in their body form and all that stuff as
a result of historical processes natural
selection
a random process called genetic drift
but we tend to become different as our
as our populations are separated from
each other in space
so here in the
these are um
let's see
can someone focus this for me this is
not focused
i want to show and i have to read my own
graph here
uh the other way okay
okay that's good right there okay
these are africans
these are people from new guinea
particularly these this is the andaman
islands they really don't belong in that
group this is new guinea the yellow here
are folks from europe
here are american indians in green
east asians
and polynesians
in a two-dimensional graph this is a
very complex statistical graph
the
two axes of which don't mean anything in
direct terms these are these are
mathematical constructs
but what you see is these are the these
are the paleo-americans the ancient
human beings of america the ones that
are complete enough all five of them the
males
to be used in a comparison like this and
you find that they're way out here
kenwick man in fact is the farthest away
and this used to have
but i took it off until we got him all
figured out this used to have our stick
man from from
the other fellow from eastern washington
way over here he's completely different
from anybody else although he could be
related to kenoic man he's not related
to the rest of him but you see they tend
to group together off to the side
they don't fit with any of these groups
at all
it gets back to that point of back in
the past
modern categories didn't have any
meaning
what it also suggests is that later
populations have maintained their
genetic interaction with each other also
known as inner marriage in a similar way
they maintain their genetic interaction
and consequently are more like each
other now than they are like their
predecessors
kind of says we're not that far apart in
time
at all
so since they're not like anybody who
are they most like well they're most
like
polynesians
and a relic population of japan
coastal asian populations so they're
most like not siberians they're very far
from siberians
this is a facial reconstruction that we
conducted by standard reconstruction
methods of kenoic man everybody likes to
say he looks like patrick stewart
put a hat on him in the likeness really
diminishes significantly it's that bald
head
if we were 30 years ago everybody say it
looks like you'll brenner
same reason he's a bald guy with fairly
prominent cheekbones
but this is what he may have looked like
based on
uh a scientific reconstruction we're
going to do another one i'm going to do
another one for a a british documentary
where we're going to do it with computer
i'm going to advise a guy but he's going
to have the computer do the work so
we'll take it one more step away from
the subjectivity
i'm just going to advise him on details
of of what this man's expression was
like most of the time to give a sense of
where the wrinkles belong on his face
that's how this has been done too he he
grimaced a great deal
for reasons it should be fairly obvious
from the physical condition he was in
but the the north americans tend to look
like the inu and
and uh
uh polonie and
polynesians most
but they can't be polynesians because
polynesians have only been polynesians
for about four thousand years
now the i know go back a lot longer so
there may be a relationship there
but i went into south america and looked
at looked at those and this is walter
nevis who's conducted some extensive
studies of of the much larger number of
human skeletons that are over 9000 years
old in south america and what he finds
is here's another reconstruction of
of an individual in south america this
is a female known as luzia you all know
about lucy from africa right
okay this is lucia this is the most
ancient american female
she goes back around thirteen thousand
years a little more than thirteen
thousand years
perhaps it's a little bit iffy as to
whether that's really the case but you
can see she doesn't really look like she
belongs here either
this is done by a british
probably one of the top three people in
the world in facial reconstruction work
this is his production
what the early south americans who they
resemble most is africans and
australians
in fact they're not sort of vaguely like
them like the north americans are
vaguely like polynesians and i knew
these guys right fall right into the
middle of the pack
it just gets more complicated all the
time but again these are forms
these aren't telling us necessarily the
whole story
but the sense that you get when you're
taking and look at them
is that
uh this is about what the north
americans may have looked like
we don't know what their hair looked
like but these are i knew people from
japan
in this smithsonian photograph from way
back the last century
you know you would not imagine this man
came from japan
nowadays nor this woman
nor anyone else in the entire group
except maybe
the one you can't see right there
this is a 19th century photograph
this is
the closest thing first kind of people
we have nowadays to what the earliest
americans the paleo americans were like
in their appearance
they might even have worn clothing about
like that they were made out of cloth
when we consider this pattern of the
earliest people
one of the things that
what i did was i went and looked at the
other skeletons in asia
and
the information about them and the
information about the earliest skeletons
in europe
and found that when we compare the
earliest asian skeletons and european
skeletons with modern human populations
we get the same outcome as the with the
early americans
the people they're most like are
australians polynesians and i know
what this suggests is that the paleo
americans the earliest people in america
are representatives of the human
prototype
the way i like to think of it is we've
got the wave of humanity emerging from
africa roughly 60 000 years ago or so
and sweeping across
the eurasian continent
over burundia and breaking on the
american shore
after that
populations diverge
and subsequently we see new people
coming in
but here we have here's one of the paleo
american females here again there's that
pragmatism i talked about and the short
face she's really has a narrow face but
then again she's been crushed
she's about that wide actually
but it doesn't change the way her mouth
is because the jaw is not crushed
but
this is one of our earliest homo sapiens
predecessors
from
from
israel
i go back again
here's female from america
there's
two
okay that worked well there's a female
from america
here's one of our earliest female
ancestors
it's not very different from the first
folks out of africa what this reminds us
is
that we are very very recently diverged
from a common ancestor
and what i hope it makes us give pause
to is this tendency to
tribalize ourselves
i'm this kind of person you're that kind
of person i'm good because i'm this kind
of person you're bad because you're that
kind of person in fact we're all sprung
from the same route very recently
and i think it's good for us to remind
ourselves of that it might cut down on
the conflict between us a little more
but what we also can see
going from oh
we don't begin to see people who look
like modern american indians who
resemble northeast asians especially in
the western united states in this area
until around seven thousand years ago
and we first see them as you might
expect in the northwest
this is the oldest one we have this and
here these extremely wide cheekbones way
out in here
as an example this fellow's face is flat
unlike the projecting faces of the
earlier americans
and he lacks that distinct ridge on the
canine he's he's lacking all the
characteristics that the early folks
have
so it looks like a secondary once the
after the northeast asian
people had diverged from the rest of the
human prototype
to become what we refer to as asian
people now
some of them migrated as a secondary
group across into north america and for
one reason or another perhaps because
they could take care of their women
better than the earlier population
came to genetically dominate
at the very least genetically dominate
the population of america and become the
people that we see today much much later
so it looks something like this instead
of that picture i showed first of
everybody coming into
america i'm showing it from the from
asia i've got it upside down on purpose
because it really starts from here
we're going from here to there
and we need to know that that's how it's
done we go from the past toward the
present and we go from asia to america
because that's how things work
we've got populations coming out of
emerging from africa going both ways one
sweeps along the south and ends up in
australia by 40 000 years ago at least
another one moves up
comes in contact with the neanderthals
and spends a lot of time banging their
head against that wall
for about ten thousand years
they finally move across here about
fifteen thousand years later than that
migration takes place at least
roughly ten fifteen thousand years after
that takes place
and
by around twenty seven thousand years
ago
we have a population occupying this
entire span this is one ecosystem back
in the glacial period it's called the
mammoth step and extends all the way
here extends all the way over into
alaska
now this population's in here
it gets cut off by the expansion of the
last glacial period it just cuts that
center right off because of cold and you
don't have anybody in there you've got
populations here and you've got
populations here and that's where we
diverge a bit
northeast asians europeans
but it looks like
the first people who came into the
americas for a lot more complex reasons
than i can tell you in the short time we
have tonight
are a combination of this wave and this
way of coming together and entering
before the divergence takes place
they probably came along the coast in
boats
using
hopping from one good spot to another
spot on boats rather than trudging
through the center of alaska and they
may have done it as long as twenty
thousand years ago
twenty thousand years ago you couldn't
go through the center of alaska like
that because it was one of the most
forbidding landscapes on the planet it
was a little bit like antarctica
especially in northeast siberia it
wasn't a place a person could live
so the story is changing
when we think people came as changing
who they were
is changing
and uh it's becoming a much much richer
story about how the americas were people
it looks like instead of a single wave
we had multiple waves of immigrants
kind of like what continues to happen
even today
so we have a process that the peopleing
of the americas is still with us it's
ongoing and it will probably continue to
go on for a number of centuries hence
thank you
[Applause]
why do i blab a long time jeez
okay what's our arrangement for
questions
let the man with the boom
give him a minute so he can get over to
you
thanks a lot
brad i don't think you mentioned that
but these these folks with the film are
from c-span 2 book tv
so if you ask questions you'll be
on that yes ma'am
could you could you speak to the the 32
000 year
date for remains in central america
uh 32 000 year date for remains in
central america are you thinking of
south america for chile or for uh pedro
farada in brazil i'm thinking brazil
okay i think
that's one that really needs some some
more careful work before we can decide
whether or not that material is actually
human created or the result of natural
rounded stones falling off a gravel
deposit on the top of a cliff smacking
another ox when they come down to the
bottom of the cliff
some folks i know some of the european
scholars believe that that material is
truly that old and is truly human-made
most of the american scholars including
most of those in south america don't buy
it yet
yes ma'am
ladies uh being in a laboratory where a
lady was doing some work and you turned
around and walked to another table and
found a skull that was similar to
kennewick man but i wasn't sure what age
that skull might have been it's 9 000
years old thank you
we radiocarbon dated it again it was
really a detective job on that one
because
that skull was undocumented
well it took us for four years to figure
that one out
the only thing we had to work with was
some soil that was in was clinging to
the inside of the cranium
about uh about half a handful of soil
so four years and about
five experts later in different aspects
of the study we figured out he came from
about 40 miles away from our kind of man
was found
it's still in the same museum it was
found in before which is um central
washington university
thank you
yes ma'am had it been accepted as indian
which one let's go yeah esko was so
undocumented nobody had any idea what it
was supposed to be it was just sitting
there
what i suspect is someone working in
their garden or digging a foundation for
a house found it because it's cut right
through the face
it was a fresh break which is really
tragic for our purposes
and the only thing there was was a skull
i'm going to get this gentleman because
i saw him
one of the most pervasive
characteristics of the asian people is
the epicanthal fold of their eye
and it still is very dominant
through america
and in the in all of siberia
is there any uh
history that is developed as to why that
maintains that when it probably occurred
as a recall of cold weather in the north
and still it's in the tropics now
he's asking about the epicanthic fold
to expand that populations of europe
have a nordic fold we tend to have the
fat pad over the right side of the eye
east asian populations tend to have the
fat pad across the top of the eye on the
eyelid what it does is help keep our you
know one of the ideas about why it
occurs anyway this is not necessarily
the certain reason
is that it helps keep the the eye cold
or excuse me from getting too cold keeps
it warm
uh
as for when it happens
absolutely no clue because
um
it's not on the bones
so we're kind of in a bad situation
there as far as epicanthic folds are
concerned what i can tell you is the
ainu don't have them
and they're not as particularly common
in the polynesian populations
so it's possible that they come after
those populations separated from each
other the north asians and these other
coastal peoples
yes sir
i'll get you next
go ahead
um i try to remember whose hand was up
but i can't always do it you talk about
this
reconstruction from south america
looking like africans and australians
right and
you have this view looking from asia
into north america across alaska what
about the reverse of that what about the
southern hemisphere what happens from
south america up through central america
into the southwest
and where and how did those people come
from australia
and africa to get to south america how
did that happen okay
here's where we have a problem
we're not necessarily saying they came
from australia or africa to south
america what it suggests is
that they're closer to the original
human form what's going on in those
those african and australian populations
is they haven't undergone a lot of the
harsher climatic conditions that other
populations have undergone
so they may not be as far diverged they
apparently aren't as far diverges from
the human prototype
so
what we're really talking about is
people who resemble those populations
and that may be telling us
the thing i just mentioned that they are
part of the
that they still resemble what the
earliest people out of africa looked
like they hadn't formed these new
characteristics that we identify as as
the characteristics of distinct races
now
well that still doesn't answer the
question about about the migration if
you if you get there yeah i mean they
probably came along that coast like i
was just talking about that's that's the
most reasonable way to go 20 000 years
ago yeah we people had boats
to get to australia at 40 000 or more
they had to have boats at 30 000 to get
to the southern islands of japan when
they crossed over to those 30 000 years
ago
so
odds are that by the time they got up to
the bering land bridge they were already
working with boats they were already
familiar with coastal
environments and coastal environments
don't vary that much what you go after
is clams fish seaweed it's always going
to be there no matter where you go so
it's a fairly easy transition to make
the only difference is you got to stay
warm in the in the farther north and
you're working with more sea mammals and
higher productivity
so it's that's the most likely way
people got here
this gentleman over here has had a
question for the longest time
i've read in the literature they said
there was also they had a theory that
you know this boat travel that they
could uh
go from northern europe follow the uh
below the ice sheets go across greenland
and then go through canada right is that
a
viable theory now that's one of the idea
i what i do is in my book is i talk
about the three major
ideas about how people came there's the
clovis root that interior siberian root
is first folks another is a suggestion
by dennis stanford of the smithsonian
and his colleague bruce bradley who's an
independent stone specialist stone tool
specialist
that clovis is so much like the solution
of europe that they think it is actually
derived from this lutron of europe as a
result of transatlantic
you know people coming around the ice
rim of the north atlantic
that explanation doesn't account for
nearly as much as the idea of coming
around the pacific rim does there are
some things that support it
but overall
the easiest explanation to account for
all the evidence we have is a crossing
that comes across the north pacific
around the north pacific yes sir
gonna keep you busy all right back and
forth
uh two questions yes um uh cheddar man
yes okay uh does cheddar man
because i i gather there's sort of a
direct descendant line to modern people
does he more resemble modern people or
does he more resemble prototypical
the model that you're showing us here
okay cheddar man is a skeleton that is
the oldest homo sapiens from england or
from the british isles
and
to give you a sense of of how important
kenwick man is he's only about six
thousand years old or six hundred years
old older than keno mcmahon is
nine thousand radiocarbon years as
opposed to 8 400 radiocarbon years
also known as 9 500 to roughly 10 300
years so they're really close together
in time
as far as physical characteristics i'm
afraid i haven't been able to get a hold
of pictures of him they're just not
running around there i tried the
internet but there was nothing i could
get a hold of
but
the thing about cheddar man is that they
found a teacher who was who was not from
the area of cheddar that the fellow was
found in
but when they ran mitochondrial dna
studies they found that he had the same
mitochondrial signature in his bones
what the press interpreted that to mean
was that this man was a direct
descendant of cheddar man
that's impossible
at least to just demonstrate that way
because mitochondrial dna has only
passed from mother to child and cheddar
man's obviously a man
what it means is that that sharing of
those that characteristic is the cheddar
man and this teacher
shared a common female ancestor sometime
in their distant past
to connect
right
do you do yeah dna i don't do it it's a
specialized process okay but i work with
colleagues who do and did someone do
that on kennewick man tried we tried to
do it on kenwick man but uh
there were a couple of problems
one of the most glaring is that they
wouldn't allow the dna specialist to use
the material they wanted to use
which was either tooth
or dense cortical bone that's the dense
bone that's thickest in our in our limbs
a small section of the femur which was
broken in large parts of which were
stolen anyway
so it's not a complete bone you could
take a section off it without altering
its its value
they didn't let them use that or the
teeth there were two teeth two wisdom
teeth that i left unaltered
when i did my studies
i didn't cast them i didn't put them in
the x-rays
i didn't put any preservative on them
because i wanted to preserve them for
scientific work
they wouldn't let them use those because
they thought well there might be some
physical anthropological evidence on the
third molars well people don't work with
third molars for physical
anthropological evidence so that didn't
work but they might have gotten it out
of that instead they use small bones
from the hands and pieces of rib that
have very thin cortical bone and a low
probability of having good dna and they
didn't get any
so that was the situation there
there's people in the back oh yes sir
somebody's got the mic
i was wondering if they had ever solved
the mystery of where the inu came from
and who they're related to
there are a lot of different ideas about
where the ainu came from
the one that is the prevailing view in
japan right now
in fact i just just read a publication
on that last week
is that they come up from southeast asia
hence their similarity to a degree to
people of australia
that they come up from the south
but genetically they believe they might
have must came from the south
uh there are indications that and that
they came from the same population that
ultimately east asians
were derived from but they made the move
before the east state northeast asians
uh separated off from the main trunk
line
the uh
as i explained a little while ago
the other possibility based on the
cultures of
japan and how they tie in with cultures
on the mainland
is that it looks like they may be tied
at least culturally to the population
that once expanded across the mammoth
step occupied everywhere from
literally from germany to the manchurian
plain
and that they may have come across after
it was no longer possible to occupy
central asia and their part of the
population got shoved off to the side
because the culture of that group or
something a culture that seems to be
derived from it moves into northern
japan
at about
14 15 000 years ago
actually a little more than more than
that ago
so they may be a combination of
ingredients
yes sir
uh yes i'm trying to keep track of the
rest of you man
yeah you said one thing that i found
quite fascinating and i you look at this
and we have a minority of people here
tonight based on the general public
and we have an issue about you know what
i mean all the people watching tv all
the people that don't care about
archaeology and all that or if they do
there there's too many other things
going on what you brought up tonight was
a
minority of population nine thousand
years ago where the men were five foot
eight the women were five foot tall the
men are all banged up i see something
that an archaeologist can't talk about
but what i see is something phenomenal
to present to the public to create an
interest here where you know obviously
archaeologists can't present it is there
anything like the discovery show pbs or
anything that's going to come out that's
going to talk about that difference so
that people that are flipping through
channel surfing are going to stop for a
moment and listen something and boss
possibly that input going back to the
legislature will make them reevaluate
what's going to happen next tuesday yeah
wow
good
i don't think i could say much more
about that
well
what i've tried to do in the in my book
is to actually present
these ideas the evidence that we have
to the general public
my purpose isn't really to to influence
folks
politics or anything like that is to say
wow this is fascinating look at this
just as you said
um
i think they're relatively there's a lot
of people here tonight but
it's an awfully beautiful night out and
we don't get those very often in
portland so
that's probably why we have a small
number of people
there is an anova show called mystery
the first americans that does address
this and you know is a re-shown from
time to time and is available from nova
and i know it's used in classrooms and
stuff like that in colleges and probably
in grade schools not grade schools but
high schools as well
kennewick man as it turns out has become
a teaching module in
washington schools i don't know about
oregon schools but in washington schools
they do it around the middle school
time and they use it to discuss a whole
lot of different things
what you can learn about people from
from biology for example or or some of
the you know
politics of the modern world or whatever
but these kids are really excited about
this
uh interestingly enough the ones that
when i give lectures at schools the ones
that are most interested are the
hispanic kids
a lot of interest in science among those
among those kids it's really
really uh exciting to see how much
interest that there is among that
community but if kenwick man had
descendants
and if they're confined to the americas
if is a big if for somebody that long
ago by the way but if he did
they'd be among all populations but
they'd be more often in the americas and
those kids would definitely be the
descendants
so i think it's really kind of neat that
they're so excited about it
yes sir
i'll remember you're there
or genetic evidence that
north south american populations
migrated back
to asia
any any technological or physical
evidence that south american or north
american populations migrated back to
asia there are some suggestions by
people that that may have happened
but
i haven't seen anything that's
particularly convincing yet it's not out
of the question certainly
when when conditions get harsh
in a particular part of the world the
human population will crash
and leaves a vacuum
their neighbors who are doing better
than they are don't wait for them to
fill that breach
they move in
and take over that may have happened
between america and asia at some point
in time
yes man
for this early population around 9 000
years ago you talked about the
undernourishment of the female part of
the population what are the theories and
evidence behind the theories on why
there was such a difference between the
females and the males for example was a
fragile
body posture thought to be attractive or
just not enough food to go around for
the general
populace well you know
did everybody hear that one
why are the females different 9 000
years ago is it because
is it because of the nutritional
situation is it because of
preference for small slender females
what what is what is the theory about
that well you're talking to the first
person who's noticed it
and it hasn't gotten into the general
discussion yet so
we don't have a prevailing point of view
there
what i would say is that
it's going to be really hard to be
female in those times
you're the one who's
you know
undergoing the
monthly um
basically the monthly exposure to
pathogens for one thing
you're also transporting
uh babies in
the incubator
with in a population that's moving
frequently
from place to place and you've got to
carry your stuff with you as you move
and these technologies are not the real
simple technologies that you see in some
of the later populations they're really
pretty complex technologies
so that's a major burden on the females
once the kid is born you got a baby on
your hip
and you're nursing the baby at the same
time and if your food supply gets short
your chances of making it through that
process aren't very good
so i think that's the most likely reason
that we're seeing a high mortality rate
in the females is it's just pretty harsh
it just puts a lot of the the way of
life puts a lot of strain on the females
the nutritional
break
it may be that the males are really kind
of dominating the control of the food
supply and i know the feminists in the
audience would find that particularly
interesting
but uh it uh it is one thing that may be
taking place
in there because the males are pretty
big and robust and the females are
really very small yes
later on in the years i think you showed
that maybe during the first 15 years of
the female life there was
malnutrition during each year possibly
right one of the problems we have there
and that's something i should have
explained as i was going along there
our females are younger than our males
are
i
it's only when an adult is fairly
restless
as we get older our body is actually
remodeling our bone it replaces all that
bone in those in the shafts where that
stuff is is seen so by the time kenwick
man got to his age we x-rayed his bones
but he's resorbed a lot of that bone and
rebuilt it
and we don't know at his age whether or
not he actually ever had them
the horn shelter male does show them and
he is a tiny very delicately built man
with massive muscles on a tiny frame
um but it may have been much more
commonplace we just don't get the chance
to see it
yes
material around him has there been any
attempt to match that material to other
woven material other words in the world
other places everybody hear that one
good
yes
the attempt has been made
and guess where it matches or the only
other place that anybody has found is
that that kind of fabric is made today i
would guess northern
uh asia northern japan northern japan
among the i knew oh
whoa it gets stranger all the time
you had a question sir
you mentioned the other skull
at central washington as having red
ochre in it
has there been any attempt or actual
correlation of the
red paint culture across
northern united states
okay has there been an attempt to trace
the red paint culture across the united
states it's a red paint culture
northeastern us and and uh northern
coastal
atlantic
where folks are buried in just masses of
hematite pigment
of red ochre
and has it is there been a trait
attempt to trace it across
not really that but what we do see is in
the earlier americans
some of the populations bury their dead
in intact
some of them cremate their dead it's
it's pretty close to 50 50 number wise
cremation and
and
intact burial
a lot of them are secondary bundle
burials where the body is deteriorated
and they're you know
packed up in a package of bones and
transported some place to be buried
but it seems that it's common among homo
sapiens globally early on
to have red ochre smeared on the body
when in death the earliest homo sapiens
in europe do it the earliest homo
sapiens in australia did it we see it
fairly commonly at least in the early
late early post-plexus in skeletons in
east asia the oldest skeletons that we
have from east asia the the jogojian
skeletons the upper cape jogodan
are
from the manchurian plain
also are in red ochre
so there's a tremendous amount of
similarity that entire population that
goes across the mammoth step the bodies
are buried in red ochre they're buried
with you know mammoth shafts and needles
and all kinds of interesting things
there's a similarity of dates if that's
been established oh the red the red
ochre culture is a bit later it's on the
order of 6000 a little bit later
so there's a good time gap in there it
seems that people take to the idea of
red pigmentation in dead folks because
deadpool's bodies look gray they don't
look very lively
and red pigment kind of
you know perks them up a little bit i
think that may have something to do with
it it wasn't your wasn't yours your
skull i just i'm
central washington wasn't that at a 9
000 year old skull also yes the central
washington once it also had red ochre
right
right there's one from um colorado
there's a female with red ochre there's
another
individual
in
southern new mexico that's buried in red
ochre female from southern texas was in
red ochre
and
the horn shelter male was it wasn't
packed in red ochre wasn't smeared on
him but he had a lump of it he and his
and the girl who was with him had it
buried with them so it's a fairly common
thing
in the substrate of human populations
both here and elsewhere
oh okay one more
it's going to say just about warming out
yes
oh you go ahead if you want to ask all
right uh has anybody done any chemical
studies of that red ochre to to see for
common source or distribution uh has
anybody done any studies of the red
ochre to see if there's a common source
or distribution no not yet
uh red okra hematite is a really common
element it's just iron oxide
just an incidental question the knife
that you found with kendall command what
was the story behind that
happenstance
what was the story behind the knife with
kennewick man
happenstance i think that is i didn't
have his humorous at the time i was
first looking at it but i think his
humor is also
a notch in the
knee
so it may have simply have been
coincidence that they were there
together
okay
i like this part so go ahead
and which way would you bet next tuesday
okay we are going to close on that one
well i've got you there
i'm not a betting man
thank you very much
jim chatters is a forensic
anthropologist his book ancient
encounters kennewick man and the first
americans was published last june by
simon schuster
to read an excerpt of the book go to
www.simonsays.com
next week on history on book tv author
dan kersman discusses the san francisco
earthquake that occurred on april 18 19